winter's coming and the night is dark
and full of terrors Game of Thrones
season 6 episode 7 the broken man this
is your warning I don't to spoil their
free anymore and let's get right to the
titular broken man Sandor Clegane the
Hound is alive I wish I could say I was
surprised but we've got we've had enough
characters coming back lately who you
know some were actually flat-out dead
others we have presumed dead or we just
hadn't seen for a long time that I
wasn't shocked to see him that said I
was very happy to see him they got him
kind of channeling the Rambo thing here
worries trying to put that life behind
him but it basically kind of hunts him
down this is a case where the execution
really sells it ian mcshane was a great
fine to play the part of the former
soldier turned pacifist kind of
character he totally sells him but it's
a very cliche pie is it honestly it's a
pretty cliched little mini arc that they
give him but I'm so happy to see him
again and he's doing the part very well
anemic Shane is so good that it still
works even those fairly click cliche and
actually I'm gonna say as a whole I'm
becoming slightly concerned about the
show because it I feel like it's now now
that we're getting into the home stretch
and the story starting to wrap up it's
actually starting to fall into a lot of
the sort of fantasy story cliches that
it's avoided up to this point and yeah
you know what it feels like it feels
like the first five seasons or so is all
the dark history back story that goes on
in the background of most fantasy
stories and now we are into the main
sort of adventure thrust that most
fantasy stories I actually bother
telling which means we're in the part
where characters can't drop date because
we actually need them to live to serve a
function to get to the end now I don't
know how much of that has to do with the
showrunners who at this point have
surpassed what george RR martin is
written in this is them doing that or if
this was always going to be the case and
it's just the inevitability of the story
of now sort of coming to a head and
finally getting to a wrapping up point
or at least steaming towards it I'm not
going to necessarily
that I don't like it but the show as a
whole is becoming a little bit more
predictable I'm not honestly sure there
was really a way around that unless they
just wanted to draw a line in San and
give really unsatisfactory conclusions
to these various characters and stories
it would necessarily dampen my enjoyment
of this episode I did enjoyed this
episode I just I had that thought
towards the end of watching and I just
wanted to get it out there what else we
got the blackfish we finally see him for
the first time in years and after two
episodes of tzm he takes up the screen
and handles it pretty well stubborn old
man I like stubborn old men just sort of
as a construct as a stereotype and he
fills it very well I was happy to see
him I liked him facing down Jamie I like
that they found something for brawn to
do because I've been missing him I
really love the scene between Theon and
Yara I thought that was a great bit of
bonding between the two of them but
still really maintain their character I
mean cuz these are these aren't the
kinds of characters that lend themselves
to bonding scenes is just not those kind
of people but they found a way to keep
them true to their characters but still
have a nice bit of bonding between them
and I thought that was a really great
scene Marjorie you didn't let me down
she is doing really good work selling
that you know she drank the kool-aid and
she's in on this but then I saw her you
know take Diana rate yahoo yo lady
Elena's hand and hold on I'm like she
just slipped her something she's still
in there John going about gathering up
his army to try and retake Winterfell
I'm kind of hoping that Ramses gonna get
killed at the end of the season if the
season chooses to climax with the their
attempt to retake Winterfell oh and
consents to kill him that would be great
and stance is doing really good work
here and you know she's really making a
point of trying to live up to the name
of stark and i love the scene where
they're at house mormont trying to get
them to pledge what ends up just being
62 men and i love that girl she is
awesome because we've seen a fair amount
of child rulers or you know noble
children or whatever and she is
completely unlike any we've ever seen
this is a tough kid who has stepped up
to the role and yeah that was just that
was just a great scene are you getting
stabbed was a little disappointing i
guess not so much in concept you know I
suppose they have to raise the stakes
and making I'm sort of read
ray just in how much dangerous you can't
trust anybody that she sees but I mean I
saw that woman on that little bridge
Medina so they thought well that's
that's the girl i called it immediately
and so for aria to fall for that one I
saw it coming it was annoying but like I
said there's a fair amount that goes on
in this episode it's kind of all
predictable but that said there was a
lot that made me smile there was a lot
that I enjoyed and I think that even if
the show starts entering into overall
story cliches a little bit more it's so
far at least it's executing them well
enough that I'm gone good to roll that
I'm still going to get enjoyment out of
it so yes that's about it for me on this
one caught up on game of thrones what
were your thoughts on this latest
episode whatever they were drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe follow me on Twitter right
council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned